and that lineup will face this veteran
lefty hun jin ryu this will be his 30th
start on the year and you can see a
little bit of a mixed bag although he's
got really good control only 35 watts
and 159 and two thirds inning dungeon
ryu has had a very difficult last month
on the mound for the blue jays it's been
a jekyll and hyde seesaw affair
but mostly it's been tough because there
haven't been a lot of innings logged and
a lot of runs have been scored against
him lefty's pitch chopped up the middle
of the diamond long second bounce
handled by bechet unloatious the throw
to first base and gets the out on lemay
here so here's anthony rizzo 2-2
rounded up the middle and past the
diving simeon into center field a base
hit for rizzo two strikes here really
shorten up put the ball in play i mean
that's nothing more than a ground ball
up the middle here's aaron judge
that one is ripped to right field and
it's going to be a base hit in front of
hernandez
and rizzo is going to go to third the
throw is
not in time as judge will go to second
this is a beautiful swing ball diving
down and away he goes with it and just
lines it to right field stands hot last
48 games 18 home runs 47 runs batted in
3-2
and he got him a big second out for
hyunjin ryu well he did the right thing
by not throwing anything over the plate
look at the depth on that breaking ball
the 2-2 pitch
swinging a pop-up on the diamond clears
the mound with ryu pointing into the sky
espional is there to make the catch and
retire the side jun jin ryu with a
little houdini action early leaves the
yankees in scoring position see tyonne
on the year back in the action tonight
he has 28 start
good control only 42 walks so two down
here's bo buchet rudder at second the
pitch the shet swings and grounds it up
the middle a base hit into center field
springer turns to the corner and it's
one nothing toronto rbi base hit for
beau buchet give that run right there to
charlie montoya rolling to dice starting
george springer getting him in the
scoring position and then beau buchett's
going to pick him up little cutter that
hangs out over the middle of the plate
well again it'll be a 2-2
and pitches hit high in the air to
right-center
there's judge
and he makes a catch then ends the
inning for toronto they get one run so
two down and here's the number nine
hitter geo urchella and the 2-2 pitch
swinging a miss herschel is down on
strikes and the yankees are retired here
in the second no runs a single with a
fueler's choice one man left
guriel
he's the sixth hitter he's hitting 285
21 homers 84 rbis i mean this team has
some power here's the 1-0
and it's hit on the ground a third
le mayo's long throw low but rizzo came
up with it for the out just it was a
bang bang play
and there's one away just no panic from
rizzo watch his footwork he's not
stretching he just backs up almost he
knows he's got time so that brings up
judge
and here is that payoff [ __ ] swung on
and hit in the air to right and deep
that ball is high it is far it is gone
judging blast now judge drills one the
other way where he really hits a lot of
his home runs over the right field fence
to tie the game all rise
here comes the judge but it looks like a
conscious effort for him to take the
ball away from ryu tonight
double first time up and now a home run
i mean aaron judge has just been on fire
well he said he didn't need his pinky to
hit so i you know pinky swear he
was telling the truth
grounded to short and stanton goes down
as the throw goes to first let's see if
he's okay
as he walks back to the yankee dugout
it'll be 9-1-2 in the blue jays order
against jameson taion
strike three chanson down looking and
now what's up with tyonne remember he
had a partial tear of a right ankle
tendon that's why he missed three starts
and it looks like it's bothering him
again and he's going to leave the game
wow dickerson the left-handed batter
corey just missed the home run his last
time up fair ball into the right field
corner
the shed in to score on an rbi double by
dickerson 2-1 blue jays
and that sweet swing is going to come
through for him again
double number five with toronto rbi
number 13.
maybe they would make the move here but
they're going to go lefty lefty right
here ryu versus rizzo left on left the
o2
served into left field that's going to
be a base hit
or shella is going to round third he's
coming home here's the throw
nut in time or shella scores well it
hits his foot the egg's got a break
there and the ball game is tied at two
on the base of by rizzo the blue jays
pulled their infield halfway in with
aaron judge coming to the player
that one has driven out to right field
and the oscar hernandez makes the catch
tagging and scoring easily is lame you
it's an rbi sac fly for aaron judge and
it's 3-2 yankees again sidewinding
righty a great job by aaron judge just
stay in there shoot the ball the other
way get the job done easily could have
got over hernandez's head if aaron boone
you'd love to see him get through this
inning you don't want anything to happen
but he is struggling with his control
it's not about stuff
and the pitch is caught on and missed
you end the inning so holmes
pitches in and out of trouble no runs no
hits and one left
stan has been one of the hottest hitters
in baseball he is the american league
player of the week is a one-two count
now against richards first and second
two outs and the pitch is cut on and hit
in the air to left that ball is high it
is far it is gone it's a three run home
run a
stantonian home run to break open the
game he's done it again
four homers in four games a three run
blast giancarlo
nosy postparlo
he hits a three-run blast and the
yankees now take a 6-2 lead you want
your big players to get hot in big games
well these are big games and big g has
come through he is on some kind of roll
so here's the one two coming to guerrero
and the fastball is it high in the air
to right judge back stops makes the
catch well in front of the track to end
the inning sereno had him
perfect one two three three two
high fly ball left field going back
dickerson looking up sia a home run for
urchella he'll take that over the hit by
pitch and in seven two yankees
so two-way the yankees are one out away
from all that good stuff
right back to peralta sets
fires and the yankees have won seven in
a row
and the magic number to make the
playoffs is down to three